einen geschärften blick auf die schulter
dieser mann wie wenige andere er
schreibt bestseller zum thema
er ist ein bekannter strafverteidiger
klar kann ferdinand von schirach schuld
juristisch auf den punkt bringen
geschult ist das was man einen menschen
persönlich vorwerfen kann
doch schuld hat noch ganz andere
gesichter die moralische schuld ein mann
verlässt die familie
ein sohn fühlt sich schuldig am tod des
vaters diese geschichte erzählt von
schirach in seinem buch tabu
der vater hatte keinen kopf mehr die
woche zwölf bleikugeln hatte sein
gesicht weggerissen das schädeldach
abgehoben
so findet der teenager sebastian von
aesch burg seinen vater vor selbstmord
nur augenblicke nach einem letzten
beiläufigen wortwechsel von nun an quält
in die frage wer trägt die schuld schuld
ist der mensch ja und das glaube ich
auch weil sie weil ein mensch sein ohne
schuld gar nicht vorstellbar ist die
wichtigere frage ist aber wie können wir
mit der schuld leben also was wir können
ihnen auch daran zerbrechen viele leute
zerbrechen an ihrer schulden und wir
viele menschen zerbrechen an ihrer
schuld obwohl es gar keine
strafrechtliche schuld ist für die
beschäftigung mit schuld hat von
schirach auch familiäre gründe
seinen namen verbindet man mit dem
seines großvaters baldur von schirach
verurteilt in den nürnberger prozessen
der enkel mag darüber nicht mehr
sprechen auch nicht mit uns
doch 2011 hat er im spiegel darüber
geschrieben
die schuld meines großvaters ist die
schuld meines großvaters es gibt keine
sippenhaft kann er ab schuld und jeder
mensch hat das recht auf eine eigene
biografie
dieses motiv zieht von schirach im buch
weiter seine figur ist traumatisiert vom
suizid des vaters verzweifelt versuchte
das wirkliche geschehen zu
rekonstruieren
immer und immer wieder
das seltsame ist dass wir die
wirklichkeit nicht wahrnehmen können wir
nehmen nur ausschnitte waren diese
ausschnitte sind für uns dann die
wahrheit wenn wir ein gerichtsverfahren
nehmen dann war keine außer vielleicht
dem angeklagten bei der tat dabei also
der richter nicht der staatsanwalt nicht
der verteidiger nicht und trotzdem mit
reden alle über diese diesem zeitpunkt
in dem das passiert ist und und besuchen
sich eine wahrheit aus den
zeugenaussagen in den beweismitteln
unser etwas zusammenzustellen
die wahrheit ist hässlich sie riecht
nach blut und kot sie ist eher
aufgeschnittene körper der weg
geschossene kopf meines vaters sagte
eschborn
der junge mann entdeckt die kunst
beschäftigt sich als fotograf obsessiv
mit der schönheit sucht in ihr nach
wahrheit und ist er nicht hat als er sie
auch hier nicht findet das schönste
gesicht ist das durchschnittlich sste
gesicht nichts weiter schönheit ist nur
symmetrie es ist so lächerlich ich bin
so lächerlich der spur der macht aus der
welt ein kunstwerk und zwar interessiert
ihn eben diese frage nach der wahrheit
wo liegt die wahrheit
und wenn man sich diese frage stellt
kommt man sehr schnell darauf dass die
institutionen die sich noch mit wahrheit
beschäftigt die justiz
die nüchternen gesetze der justiz das
senioren beim schreiben zwei
unterschiedliche methoden sich an der
schuld abzuarbeiten ferdinand von
schirach beherrscht beide das ergebnis
ist traurige aber inspirierende lektüre